multiplayer was a surprise hit with mass  effect 3 and we might get to try it out  in Andromeda soon I'm Tony and this game  spot news update is for the whole team  Andromeda's lead designer was asked on  Twitter about a possible multiplayer  test will we hear more this month odds  are good there's no word on when this  beta will start or what it will include  but you can sign up for a chance to try  it out on Bioware's website previous  news from bioware stated that  multiplayer is much more mobile this  time around and although it still ties  into the single-player campaign you  won't have to take part if you don't  want to in other news and drama de won't  have a season pass given the series  history DLC for both single and  multiplayer modes is expected so we'll  have to see how the pricing works for  now you can tune in to gamespot for tons  more coverage and gameplay clips for all  the latest on mass effect you're already  in the right place